ja das heißt quasi in diesem sieg haben
wir richtig richtig richtig viele geile
sachen und ich habe mich auch noch
gezeigt dass and portal ist und das ist
megageil
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer sieht
vorstellung von einem sieg in der
minecraft version 1.7 punkt 10 ich
glaube dass auch irgendwie verfügbar als
punkten punkten neun oder so ich würde
auf jeden fall erstmal 710 probieren
weil da probiere ich auch gerade lässt
lautet -3 74 99 86 10 12 08 07 04
daher stellen wir uns mal ganz kurz die
welt das ist nicht flachland oder
irgendwie sowas und es sind ein paar
richtig gute sachen dabei ist wurden
sachen hinzugefügt es heißt hinzugefügt
es in sachen musik vorhanden die nicht
wirklich so sind sowohl mag das gibt es
nur bei dem seed sondern das sind
wirklich so sachen wo man sich einfach
denkt okay das sind alles sachen die
wirklich minecraft man irgendwann
hinzugefügt hat aber die man in der
normalen welt nie so oft findet aber
hier haben wir zb direkt am anfang ein
sandwich dorf und wir sehen da hinten
schon im hintergrund sehen wir einen
eine pyramide bzw in diesem tempel als
tempel oder pyramide ich weiß gar nicht
und wir haben hier nämlich schon direkt
solide
das ist auf jeden fall egal wer in einer
spiele finden wir mal sehr sehr klein
vor allem sind hier sehr sehr sehr sehr
coole items vorhanden wären nämlich
direkt schon sieben obsidian man braucht
zehn für ein web portal 7 haben wir
schon in dem sie werden wir auch noch
weitere sieben finden also bleibt daran
und wir haben auf jeden fall einen
goldbarren alten helm altenstadt und
drei diamanten das ist von anfang
richtig krass und die machen die randale
arschloch meine ganzen freunde hier und
hier hinten haben wir auch eine pyramide
und da werden wir natürlich auch mal
reingehen
der sieht wie gesagt jedoch in der
beschreibung ich habe ihn habe ich das
schon gesagt ich weiß nicht aber er
steht auf jeden fall eine beschreibende
medien nicht so bild abschreiben muss
ich habe ihn von minecraft das ist eine
seite die
sehr coole sachen immer posten die haben
5000 lag bei facebook oder ihm gesucht
schaut auf jeden fall mal vorbei steht
in der beschreibung
ja ich habe mit erfolg erzielt bei cap
des mycroft humba humba humba und ja wir
waren auf jeden fall nicht so coole
sachen das gut so weit war diese drei
weiteren diamanten
womit wir uns schon eine rose
beispielsweise basteln könnten
und jetzt sind wir halt hier und haben
das da direkt daneben und da steht auch
noch immer steht auch so ein kleiner
tümpel erzählt ihr den garten links im
bild und hängt das war es nie ich hab
noch so ein paar koordinaten wo ein paar
coole sachen sind und zwar gibt es noch
ein zweites der sat nicht der
selbsternannten npc village das problem
ist einfach mal ganz gut zu den
koordinaten hier xyz koordinaten fdp
davor schreiben damit wieder hinter
importiert und ihr denkt jetzt
wahrscheinlich warum kommt denn heute
nur so eine ladies sieht vorstellung das
ist ganz einfach ich habe mir gedacht
bevor einfach mal obst bevor einfach mal
täglich gar nichts kommt mache ich
lieber eine sieht vorstellung ich war
irgendwie unter der erde des bond bevor
täglich gar nichts gemacht die beine
sieht vorstellung oder einen kleinen
block weil ich muss auch gleich direkt
wieder weg und es sind grad 34 grad und
da kann ich jetzt nicht eine stunde lang
irgendwie watt aufnehmen oder so galaxy
kommt bald auch wieder keine sorge und
deswegen hab ich gedacht lieber eine
kleine sieht vorstellung oder irgendwas
anderes kleines als dass ich irgendwie
gar nichts mache und ich habe mein
tanktop nicht an und irgendwie zu zeigen
guck mal wie viele muskeln ich hab die
habe ich nicht
da schreibt mir mal viele irma das tops
nur erzielen wenn man muskeln hat blabla
an eines etwa 34 grad und ich will nicht
nur weil du ein paar leute hier um
meckern pulli anziehen oder so nun keine
haut zu zeigen das ist ja keine ahnung
ich sterbe sonst wir haben auf jeden
fall hier auch wieder eine schmiede mit
ein paar coolen sachen hier sind die
sieben weiteren obsidian drin
die äpfel sind nicht ganz so cool aber
eine goldene für rüstung baumann fährt
auch wieder eisenwaren und kanal wasser
drin war auf jeden fall auch ganz coole
sachen und wieder ein paar freunde von
mir haben auf jeden fall die sache da
brennt gehabt der wald ab wenn wir nach
da hinten rüber schauen werde die
gleichen becken da hinten ist die wüste
jetzt links im bild dahin ist der tempel
und da ist das mpc dorf ca da kann man
theoretisch einfach hier durchfliegen
dass es auch sehr cool
ich finde dass biom sehr sehr geil hier
mit diesen ganzen kleinen bilden also
groß pilzen kann man einfach hier so
durchfliegen und ist so eine coole
ansicht von hier zu genießen und zwar
wenn man von hier von der wüste dahin
ihr wisst rübergeflogen kommt sieht man
hier einfach so durch
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bleibt und
sieht hier schon so dar um die ecke
dieses villiger dorf sieht dass seine
halt abfackelt aber dass auf jeden fall
ein sehr cooler spot ihr einzubauen da
haben wir keine höhle aber dahin nahm
eine hürde
und hier geht also einfluss lang da
haben wir das kollegium hier ist das
winterdorf und ich würde sagen das passt
nicht von dem sid aber wir gehen weiter
zu einem messer bio oder mesa bio das
ist wie ich finde wir auch mittlerweile
denke ich mitbekommen habt das aller
coolste was hier hinzugefügt wurde weil
es nicht einfach ein könig der löwen so
krass erinnert und weil ich die berge
hier
ich find die berge hier viel viel viel
viel cooler als die normalen berg wenn
wir zum beispiel mal hinten hin schauen
sondern bergner
er besteht nur aus erde wenn dem leser
ich habe solche frame einbrüche in
diesem neuen version der dass es so
traurig das liegt nicht an mein pc das
sieht ja jedenfalls finde ich dass hier
viel cooler dass die berge unterteilt
sind und das sind macht die berge gleich
viel attraktiver und vor allem auch wenn
wir mal von hier hinten wenn wir hinten
hin fliegen sehen wir ganz am ende
der generierung einen berg in einen berg
in schatten und dass er nämlich
besonders krass anknüpfen wo sie da
hinten geht alles dir außer dahinten die
schwarze region das ist nicht unser land
und alles mögliche
das was auch so krass tunkel und in
schatten und so dass schatten land und
so weiß nicht einmal als könig der löwen
weil ein vogel
das ist schlecht für die andere person
oder so und das coole ist auch hier oben
haben wir so ein kleines spot wir haben
hier oben was wo man nicht richtig cool
hin bauen kann wo man richtig coole
sachen in bonn kann und zwar ist man
hier höher als diese ganze andere
minecraft welt hier und hat hier quasi
sonst bot und das hier sieht auch
einfach so extrem grades davon
sorry aber dafür muss ich jetzt mal eben
ganz kurze screenshot machen das ist ja
mal so geil hier also dieses medium ist
echt ich feier dieses biom bis zum mond
das ist ja so krass geil
das ist ja so cool weil sie nicht ich
liebe diese biome irgendwie dieses
medium finde ich ist das alles was hier
hinzugefügt wurde auch mit diesem
gefärbten ton und alles sehr sehr cool
aber darum sollte ich gehen soll wir
gehen direkt weiter zu einem eis bikes
planes bio was ebenfalls dazu geführt
wurde als kathi sonneberg das sehr sehr
angenehm gerade da tpm uns einfach mal
2006 123 74 ist die y koordinaten die
zeit coni hat es 34 14
so war kurz 31 hier ist das eis bei
explains biom auch sehr cool ich habe ja
schon anfang gesagt das ist kein zieht
mit so sachen wie man denkt vor acht das
ist nur bei diesem ziel hinzugekommen
sondern das sind dann wirklich so alle
sachen die irgendwie minecraft man mit
dem laufe der zeit so gefügt hat aber
die man in so einem normalen normalen
welt nie so alle wirklich zusammen
findet diesen ordner relativ weit
auseinander aber ihr habt jetzt die
koordinaten zum beispiel an ihren so ein
privat könnte ganz mal anschauen und für
all das medium lohnt sich anzuschauen
sehr sehr schön und auf dieses eisbergs
pentium umgeben von im winter
landschaften von einem fluss und
dahinten quillt auch im voraus ich
glaube da war das ja da kommt sogar aus
ich weiß nicht ob ich das sage aber tut
sie dann gehen wir weiter zu einem
marsch mumbai um
das ist ebenfalls vorhanden dieses sieht
4027 89 und 78 und - 2288 und dann sind
wir hier
da wo gar keinen much to me home ist
weil ich mich vertippt hat moment 4027
78 78 haben acht vergessen 22 88 sah ich
hab nur 287 1 gegeben
220 angegeben das ist eine riesige smart
schwimm bio nein das ist eigentlich
relativ klein
das ist alles nämlich erscheint mir geht
nämlich auch ein bisschen weiter und war
vorne wundert sich das ganze dann auch
ab und an ist es vorbei aber ich finde
firma schunk büro
das alles sei für diese pilze kühl wo
man einfach mit einer schüssel rechts
drauf machen muss mann hat unendlich
suppen
das ist sehr sehr sehr sehr cool das ist
quasi schon das ganze millionen ich
finde es sehr gut dass wir so eine bucht
haben wo man sich dann eventuell auch
mal hin bauen kann wo man so einen
kleinen fisch sind da ich machen kann
alles mögliche sein park coole sachen
sind auf jeden fall vorhanden und die
letzte sache es gibt auch noch 1000 für
wien zum tanzen sollen so aber die muss
ich mir gar nicht zeigen
aber wenn ihr in saint volt habe ich
mich auch schon die koordinaten und
portale müssen ihr eure hände augen
perlen für ausgeben und 23 21 dasinger
ihr müsst euch nur untergraben an dieser
stelle und dann wenn ihr irgendwann ganz
weit runter gekommen seid kommt ihr dort
an bei den silber fischen in denen mit
denen ich im tief noch viel spaß haben
werde werde ich in den nächsten folgen
unter anderem heute bekomme und morgen
bei mir sind es hasste silberfische und
also wir hier im moment und können auch
hier noch mal so ein bisschen rum gurken
im end und ich war schon zombies und
alles mögliche zum beispiel mal hier
eben hier runter laufen hier noch fackel
den satz ich runtergefallen
wir sind überall so ein paar coole
sachen die man auf jeden fall entdecken
kann
und ja das heißt quasi in diesem sieg
haben wir richtig richtig richtig viele
geile sachen und ich habe mich auch noch
gezeigt dass ein portal ist und das ist
ja mal mega geil und ich würde sagen tut
mir leid dass jetzt so eine kleine puppe
sieht vorstellen wo sieht vorstellung
haben und ich so viele frame einbrüche
habe und ich ein bisschen schnell reden
und alles mögliche aber ich muss direkt
wieder weg und ich habe jetzt gesagt
komm ich mache jetzt den stress machen
video bevor hier gar nichts heute von
mir habt
und wenn euch das gefällt meine
leidenschaft
da zeigte mit einem markig und schreibt
eventuell in kommentare das eben auch
aus diesem zieht hier entdeckt habt und
auch eventuelle ob ihr besseres dies
kennt die ich auch mal vorstellen soll
und ich wünsche dir noch ein bisschen
rum kann ich eigentlich ist er wieder
weg muss kleiner skispaß arschloch typ
aus mal die tür kaputt wie viele silber
für schärfe aus den wänden kommen
oder kommt gar nicht so viele doch da
kommen wir einmal so ein paar selber
kaputt zu hassen die mich jetzt
eigentlich
na gut egal